let me get this straight you asked me if
you and I and my friends and my mother
were all on a ship that was thinking and
I could only save one of you who would I
save and I said I'd rather save my
mother and that's the wrong answer how
can I be the wrong answer you can swim
she can't swim she can't even doggy
paddle and I wonder why people don't do
this premarital thing anymore this is a
pretty good reason I've need counseling
seeing the dead bodies of my family and
friends floating all around me bye Jimmy
bye Vince ma no sorry I can't save you
I'm married now but it's okay mom she's
she's a lot like you okay I'm sorry I
didn't mean that just throw it out I
know you're nothing like my mother and
at times you you can't even stand to be
around her but the poor woman is dead
for pete's sake she's bloated and
decaying on the bottom of the ocean
floor but to answer your question I
would save you even if even if my mother
was screaming my name at the top of her
old tired and soon-to-be decay lungs I
would save you are you happy now